alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
like i want to say thank you so much god
first of all
hey first of all i wanna say
alhamdulillah
i'm sure you will appreciate when you
can connect it to something you're
familiar
with in the winner by submission you
know kimura
[Music]
now let's start off with what he's doing
here this is not just particular to him
you'll see many people who
want to keep it humble and who are
thankful and grateful
they point up pointing up to the one up
above up above the creation
up above the heavens in the universe the
one who created this whole universe
the galaxies the seven seas everything
in this
world isn't he not worthy of all praise
and things and that's what he's doing
because people become very arrogant and
this is something we have to be very
very careful of and we can all take a
lesson from this to keep it humble to
keep it humble you cannot go wrong with
keeping it humble arrogance will get you
lost
we'll lose your friends who likes to be
around arrogant people
and at the end failure failure at the
end
why is he putting his face on the ground
what's he doing kissing the ground
but let me connect it because the point
was if i can if we can connect it to
something that you are familiar with
someone
who you're familiar with you're probably
gonna appreciate it a lot more you might
even
start doing it and if something works
if it's gonna help improve your life
why not give it a try and check this out
you know jesus we know jesus
i mean did you know muslims love jesus
there's this fighter
here if anyone knows who he is he's
wearing a he's another
mixed martial arts fighter he's got a
he's got a shirt on
talking about how muslims love jesus did
you know that so if you're a
khabib fan you've learned something
already and you'll see that muslims they
have a deep
reverence and love for jesus as a mighty
messenger who was sent
just like abraham knowing all the other
messengers calling people to
connect with the one who gave us these
abilities
these gifts in life like khabib was
given
some very talented athlete and
and he's acknowledging that this is from
the creator and now
again he's taking it a step further and
just like
jesus and related to someone you know
jesus in the gospel of matthew 26 39 it
says that he went and he went a little
further and he fell
on his face and prayed to god
isn't that amazing this is something
that habib doing
not only him but muslims 1.7
billion human beings and muslim is
simply one who
surrenders who submits himself not to a
man
not to a woman not to money not to fame
not to anything or anyone
but to the creator up above isn't that
beautiful do you learn something already
he's doing what all the prophets of god
did
so it shouldn't be next time you see him
do that next time you're a fan of khabib
and you see you see him fighting at the
end
and if he wins god willing and he
prostrate he puts his head
on the floor you can connect it now you
watch this you say
oh he's doing what jesus did he's giving
praise and thanks
keeping it humble excuse me guys
alhamdulillah now let's move on to the
next thing what he said he said some
some words now sometimes when we hear
something in another
language we can't appreciate it excuse
me guys
alhamdulillah i want to say something he
says
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
what does that mean why is he saying
something in
another language in arabic now i want to
connect this again
back to the one i'm sure many christians
who love jesus people who aren't
even maybe christian but they heard
jesus they have they have a connection
to him
do you know that jesus he called on the
creator if you ever watch the
the passion of christ
[Music]
in arabic it's just allah this is the
creator we're talking about
and he is saying alhamdulillah
[Applause]
everything god gave me so again he's
keeping
it humble if anything we could take away
from this video is is
is that quality of keeping it humble we
got too much
we're all susceptible to it ego the ego
can take over and you become very
arrogant who likes to be around arrogant
people
keeping it humble again he's saying
alhamdulillah it's just like saying
thank you god
everything god gave me very simple now
you're gonna preach can you appreciate
that